Agent Lane’s eyes scanned over the document
he’d been sent.
The decryption program had finished unraveling
the sensitive data that the SCP Foundation’s
cyber security kept hidden beneath layers
of encryption.
It had been a few hours since he’d received
the leaked document, sent to him from a mole
that had been active within the ranks of Foundation
personnel for some time.
And as for what was on this secret document?
It was an intake list, the records and names
of everyone recently brought into D Class.
Lane scoured the rows upon rows of inmates,
violent criminals, the worst of the worst
that the Foundation used as human lab rats.
Then, his eyes settled over one name, the
exact one he’d been looking for: the true
identity of a man codenamed ‘The Hatchet’,
a mass murderer, responsible for co-ordinating
multiple acts of international terrorism.
But to Agent Lane, this man wasn’t a threat
to be feared: he was bait in a trap for something
far worse.
The Global Occult Coalition had long been
the face of officially sanctioned legitimacy
in the fight against the anomalous.
While the SCP Foundation operated in a more
clandestine fashion, the GOC was operated
by and acted under the authority of the United
Nations.
They were mandated with policing the paranormal
world, a role nobody in the GOC took lightly.
Their ultimate goal was a world rid of all
anomalies; while the Foundation opted for
containment, the Coalition preferred extermination.
But despite this fundamental difference in
their operational structures, the two organizations
maintained a fragile alliance… which was
why Agent Lane needed bait in order for his
plan to work.
The objective was simple: kill SCP-096, also
known as the Shy Guy.
An anomalous entity with a long, disproportionate
human body that could use impossible speeds
to kill anyone that looked at its face: even
through an image.
That was what worried the GOC, it seemed all
too easy for SCP-096 to be used as a weapon,
especially for assassinations.
It wouldn’t take much for the Foundation
to mail a photo of SCP-096 to anyone, say
a politician who opposed them, or the head
of another Group of Interest.
Then, all they’d have to do is sit back
and wait as SCP-096 dispatched its unwitting
target, along with any witnesses that happened
to see it appear.
So, the Coalition had decided it was time
to take the Shy Guy off the board, before
anyone got any unsavory ideas.
But there was still one issue with that.
Given the GOC and SCP Foundation’s rocky
relationship, Agent Lane had been instructed
to leave no trace of the Coalition’s involvement.
He needed someone else to be responsible for
the actual elimination of SCP-096, so that
the GOC could deny any and all involvement.
That was when he’d gotten the idea, who
better to call on for a covert, strictly off-the-books
mission?
Only one of the world’s most elite special
forces units, with no affiliation to the GOC
whatsoever: Delta Force.
Engineering a scenario where Lane could get
the Deltas to take out SCP-096 was going to
be tricky.
He couldn’t give them a direct order to
kill the creature, that could too easily lead
back to the GOC.
So, the mastermind behind this mission needed
to think outside the box: how could he get
the attention of Delta Force?
Well, by offering up one of the world’s
most wanted terrorists.
After all, Delta Force was renowned for undertaking
missions that involved counter-terrorism,
as well as the securing – and sometimes
elimination – of high-value targets.
And that was where The Hatchet came into the
plan.
Given the severity and extreme nature of his
many crimes, he was certainly considered high
value by the US Government.
However, it was while awaiting trial that
the Hatchet had disappeared under mysterious
circumstances.
The official story was he had died in prison
following a fight with another inmate, but
rumors circulated about an escape attempt.
Of course, neither were correct.
Now Agent Lane knew the truth: the Foundation
had him.
Which meant he was within the reach of the
GOC.
Issuing a coded command to his mole working
inside the SCP Foundation, Lane instructed
that the Hatchet would be making an escape
of sorts; at least, that’s how it would
appear.
But it would really be completely staged.
Under the cover of night, the mole drugged
and kidnapped the Hatchet, breaking open an
air vent and making it look like someone had
crawled their way through.
Nobody had, and instead, the Hatchet was carried,
unconscious, to a Foundation vehicle the mole
had hotwired; if he drove off in his own car,
the Foundation would be able to trace the
escape back to him, and then the GOC.
Bundling the terrorist into the trunk, the
mole drove several miles away from the Foundation
site, to an extraction point where Agent Lane
was waiting.
“So, he’s how you’re going to lure out
the Delta Force,” the mole said as he and
Lane lifted the Hatchet aboard a chopper.
“But how are you going to be SCP-096 to
come too?
The Foundation keeps it crying in that cell.”
“They can’t stop it getting out when somebody
sees it, though, right?”
Lane replied.
“Yeah, it moves way too fast,” the mole
confirmed.
“All somebody has to do is look at it, and
it can get out, even when-”
“Even when they look at a picture of it,”
the agent finished his sentence.
“Oh,” the mole gasped, realization spreading
across his face.
“Our friend the Hatchet here isn’t just
bait to lure out Delta Force,” Agent Lane
explained.
“He’s bait for both; SCP-096 and Delta
will both be coming after him.
That way, as far as the Foundation knows,
SCP-096 will be killed during a standard Delta
Force mission to recapture an on-the-run terrorist
mastermind.
And meanwhile, the GOC gets complete deniability.
It was nothing to do with us; we weren’t
involved.”
“Perfect scapegoat,” the mole commented.
“Thing is, if this is meant to be such a
covert mission, then why risk security by
telling me?”
“Dead men don’t talk,” Agent Lane replied
quietly, pulling a silenced handgun from his
holster and squeezing the trigger, firing
three times for good measure.
With the loose end tied up, nothing linked
the Global Occult Coalition to the Hatchet’s
apparent ‘escape’.
Sure enough, the Foundation fell for it hook,
line, and sinker.
While they were busy locking down the facility,
searing the air vents that they believed their
D Class prisoner had escaped through, Agent
Lane had the Hatchet handcuffed, securely
under lock and key.
The helicopter took them a short distance
to a quiet airstrip, where they boarded an
unchartered plane to a safehouse.
To avoid any further links to the GOC, Lane
had to transport the Hatchet as off the grid
as possible, until he got him to their destination.
Even that, the safehouse, couldn’t be one
the GOC had ever used before.
Any link and the Foundation, or Delta Force,
would smell a rat.
The leaked intelligence that was soon received
by Delta Force seemed to confirm their worst
fears: not only was the Hatchet still alive,
but he was free and apparently hiding out
in a safehouse.
While they would never publicly acknowledge
the unit’s activities, the Department of
Defence issued an objective to Delta Force:
track down the Hatchet to his current location
and either capture him, or kill him.
A squad of some of the most highly trained
United States troops were assembled.
Before joining Delta Force, most of them had
been recruited from the elite 75th Ranger
Regiment, as well as from other branches of
Special Forces and the wider US Army.
The team wasn’t told by their commander
– whose identity was classified – where
they were going.
All the information they were given was only
the essentials; just that there was a high-value
target holed up in a safehouse.
Although they had no idea there would actually
be two; only the second was unlike anything
the Deltas had ever seen…
Agent Lane was watching over hidden infrared
cameras; they were set to cut out the minute
the lights came on.
No point in going to all this trouble only
to see SCP-096 on his feed and be killed too.
Silently, using all the skills in stealth
that they’d been trained in, the squad of
Delta Force operators slipped into the safehouse.
Their movements were perfectly synchronized,
practiced hours and hours at a time.
They checked corners, two would sweep one
room of the building whilst two more protected
them, and none of them would move on until
they’d confirmed the area was clear.
Floor by floor, they worked their way up the
building, ascending closer and closer to where
the Hatchet was.
The operators were fully expecting to meet
armed resistance from the Hatchet’s loyalists
when they arrived; the fact the place was
so quiet didn’t seem right.
In fact, none of the lights were on either,
the Delta Force unit needed to wear night
vision just to navigate their way around.
Despite it seeming suspicious, none of them
could have guessed it was intentional: Agent
Lane had set everything up to work perfectly.
Arriving at one room, the special forces troops
could hear the sound of someone behind the
door.
Their voice was muffled, like something was
obstructing their mouth and preventing them
from speaking.
This was it, the team lined up against the
nearest wall and placed an explosive charge
on the door.
With a mighty explosion, the entrance burst
wide open and the team filed in, weapons trained
on the room’s sole occupant.
They could see, through the hazy green of
their goggles, a figure sat in a chair…
no, restrained to a chair, with something
in front of him.
It looked like a frame, a photograph in a
frame.
Who sits in front of a photo in the dark?
Suddenly, the lights came up, causing the
operators’ night vision goggles to beam
bright white straight into their eyes.
The second the lights came on, the cameras
Agent Lane was watching through cut off, and
he purged the hard drive they were connected
to, leaving no recording, no evidence of the
situation he’d engineered.
Meanwhile, as the room was illuminated, the
first of the Delta Force team to take off
his goggles saw who it was tied to the chair.
It was the Hatchet, bound by his wrists and
ankles, eyes pried open so he couldn’t look
away from the framed photo in front of him…
a photo of SCP-096.
Suddenly, within the blink of an eye, the
tall, slender creature had appeared in the
room with the captive terrorist.
The Deltas, removing their goggles, turned
in horror to see SCP-096 slaughter their target.
And the moment they looked at it, the wailing
Shy Guy started bearing down on them too.
“Contact!”
their captain yelled.
“Open fire, hostile contact!”
They started shooting, their bullets having
little effect on the looming, wiry monster
as it came at each of the squad, one by one.
The muzzle flashes illuminated the oncoming
anomaly, those brief glimpses of it in the
flickering of gunfire made it look all the
more horrifying.
Screams filled the room, echoing through the
building as SCP-096 decimated the team that
had unknowingly been sent in to kill it.
One of the Deltas was still struggling with
his night vision, unable to detach them from
his face thanks to a clasp that had gotten
stuck.
All he could hear were his squad mates around
him being killed, but with no way of seeing
what was happening.
“Private!”
the captain gurgled; he sounded hurt, but
the operator couldn’t see how badly, or
what had attacked him.
“Shoot this thing!
Shoot it now!”
“I can’t see, sir!” he yelled back,
goggles still strapped to his face, eyes shut
to keep out the searing whiteness.
“Ten o’clock!”
the captain replied, directing his subordinate
to aim his weapon slightly to the left.
There was a sickening twisting sound, and
the Captain’s voice cut out.
The Private fired, his shot winging the creature.
It whimpered, then seemed to vanish as quickly
as it had arrived.
Pulling a combat knife from a sheath on his
belt, the operator was able to cut the strap
keeping the goggles over his eyes.
When his vision cleared, he looked around
to see an empty room, smeared in blood.
Even the Hatchet hadn’t survived, killed
in the chair he’d been held in.
The operator took a closer look at the photo
the terrorist had been made to look directly
at.
It was hideous, tall, and thin.
arms that looked too long and a huge mouth.
And now it was behind him.
He’d gotten lucky, it had left the Private
alone because he hadn’t seen it.
But now he had, and SCP-096 knew.
It always knew, and despite the best efforts
of those trying to stop it, it would never
stop killing anyone that looked at it.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go and check out “CAN SCP-096 CHASE
ITS VICTIMS ACROSS THE MULTIVERSE?”
and “SCP-096 TALE A LESSON IN POWER” for
more 096 antics!